netflix is set to unleash a wave of
exciting new content throughout the
month of september
suck on what to stream here are the best
movies and tv shows to watch on netflix
in september 2020
plus everything to see before it's gone
for good in september 2020 netflix
subscribers can go
back to the back to the future film
franchise the streamer introduced the
full trilogy to its digital shelves in
may 2020
then removed them in july 2020 but just
a couple of months later marty mcfly and
doc brown will return to netflix in
their complete trilogy glory
anyone who missed out over the summer
can stream all three movies beginning on
september 1st
the sci-fi action fun doesn't end there
though also headed to netflix next month
is freaks you're one of us the
action-packed german
superhero film that follows working mom
wendy as she learns
she possesses powers of invulnerability
and super strength
which were previously suppressed by
medication wendy teams up with two
other powered people to seek out others
just like them
but their search soon grows complicated
as they end up uncovering a conspiracy
bigger than they ever thought could
exist freaks you're one of us
hits netflix september 2nd later in the
month catch the 2011 sci-fi sports movie
real steel
starring hugh jackman is a former boxer
whose life changes in major ways after
robots come to replace human combatants
into sports
struggling to make ends meet by building
robots out of scrap metal
charlie reunites with his estranged son
max and together they exact a plan that
will put their names on the map
create a bot that can become a champion
real steel will drop on netflix on
september 24th
in september 2020 netflix is intent on
making sure that we all get the lion's
share of laughs the first of the month
alone gives us a few modern classics
including 2002's hilarious and heartfelt
barbershop
2011's striptastic magic mike and the
2008 buddy stoner comedy pineapple
express
there are also some more retro offerings
on the way for those who want to tickle
their funny bones on the way down memory
lane
there's 1993's coneheads which stars dan
aykroyd and jane curtin as the heads of
the clueless alien family they
popularized on saturday night live
and 1978's grease a timeless tale worthy
of at least a dozen more re-watches
other comedy selections include the 2005
film adaptation of the broadway play of
the producers with matthew broderick and
nathan lane
which hits netflix on september 1st how
to train your dragon 2 which arrives on
september 11th
and 2005's waiting which is required
viewing for anyone who has ever worked
in a service industry
popping up on netflix on september 23rd
there's also the cameron diaz starring
bad teacher the 2011 feature about a
well subpar educator that drops on
september 27th
all right let's do this those wanting
even more laughs can stream a quartz out
of new stand-up specials on netflix in
september 2020
last comic standing season seven winner
felipe esparza whose previous specials
they're not gonna laugh at you and
translate this
aired on showtime and hbo respectively
will make his netflix debut with bad
decisions on september 1st
then on september 3rd brazilian comic
alfonso pagilla
brings his debut set classless to the
streamer veteran british comic michael
mcintyre takes over the spotlight on the
15th with a brand new batch of material
entitled showman
and on the 29th podcaster actress and
the circle host michelle butto
unleashes her new special the aptly
titled welcome to bootopia
while there aren't a ton of new drama
selections heading to netflix in
september
the few that we will see are worth
watching there's 2018's adrift
which stars shailene woodley and sam
claflin as a couple who must navigate
the treacherous waters of the pacific in
a tiny damaged boat
after their yacht is destroyed by a
hurricane then
1989's glory an acclaimed civil war
drama with a killer cast that includes
matthew broderick denzel washington
morgan freeman and andre brauer and
finally
2018's wildlife paul dano's directorial
debut that follows the travails of a
troubled couple
portrayed by jake gyllenhaal and carrie
mulligan all three movies hit netflix on
september 1st
sitting just beyond the realm of drama
in the mystery genre is one of the most
highly anticipated films of late 2020
in nola homes based on nancy springer's
enola homes mysteries series of novels
the flick stars stranger things millie
bobby brown in the title role
supported by a fantastic cast that
includes everybody's favorite british
super hunk
henry cavill as inola's older brother
sherlock
sam claflin again as her older brother
mycroft
and helena bonham carter as the trio's
mother eudoria
warner brothers originally had inola
homes set up for a theatrical release
but netflix acquired the movie in april
and will release it on september 23rd
for horror fans on netflix there are
some cool new selections to queue up
starting on september 1st
including the extraordinary 1998 b-movie
anaconda
and the 2002 silence of the lamb's
prequel red dragon but the ball really
gets rolling on september 4th with i'm
thinking of ending things
the new psychological horror film from
charlie kaufman the flick stars jesse
buckley and jesse plemons as a couple
whose trip to meet the young man's
parents goes horribly awry
it's hard to say what terror might ensue
purely based on the fact that the script
for i'm thinking of ending things comes
from kaufman
a truly original screenwriter who
provided the world with the cinematic
mind screws being john malkovich
eternal sunshine of the spotless mind
and synecdoche new york
september 10th on netflix brings us the
babysitter killer queen
the sequel to director mcgee's obscenely
enjoyable 2017 horror comedy the
babysitter
finally on september 16th subscribers
can stream the hotly anticipated film
the devil all the time the adaptation of
donald ray pollock's 2011 southern
gothic thriller novel of the same name
with a cast that includes marvel
cinematic universe alums tom holland and
sebastian stan excuse me preacher
you got time for a center september 2020
will also bring plenty of good stuff for
tv binge watchers
all eight seasons of the underrated cw
sitcom girlfriends is a pretty decent
haul in and of itself and it'll drop on
netflix on september 11th
fans of the curse of oak island and van
helsing will finally get to binge the
fourth
seasons of those shows on september 15th
and september 27th
respectively as far as netflix original
series go
hold on to your butts the first season
of the amazing looking animated series
jurassic world camp cretaceous and the
first season of the one flew over the
cuckoo's nest prequel
ratchet starring sarah paulson both drop
on september 18th
and heads up booties the second season
of john favreau's and chef
roy choi's the chef show debuts on
netflix on september 24th
if you're one of those poor souls who
missed the fourth and final season of
the widely acclaimed nbc sitcom the good
place
you can finally remedy that unfortunate
situation on september 26th
it's either this or start bloodline and
i don't know i just don't feel like i
can see kyle chandler as
anyone else but coach taylor
while many great movies and tv series
are arriving on netflix in september
2020
the streamer is still doing some
housekeeping and taking some options off
the table
in the first half of the month
subscribers will say goodbye to all
seven seasons of abc's fantasy drama
once upon a time
the first season of cold case files the
2004 sci-fi psychological horror
thriller the forgotten
and more the back half of september 2020
will see
even more removals the south korean
action horror train to busan
the first and third jurassic park movies
the underrated heath ledger flick a
knight's tale
and director david ventures oscar
winning the social network
a modern classic movie which will
celebrate its 10th anniversary on
october 1st
just a day after it leaves netflix but
you gotta come
back somewhere around the end of
november early december
it's gonna be out of control you gotta
come back for it check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one